Peter invests five thousand dollars for
three three years at 6% simple interest
Maria also invests five thousand dollars
for three years are you reading page 55
her interest rate is five point eight
percent with interest compounded
annually okay now just put your own book
down and that's the phrase I want you to
figure out in fact I want you to write
that down with me interest compounded
annually okay now it's a very important
idea to get because what does it mean
okay let's forget about the numbers that
they were thinking about for a second
and let's just come up with out their
numbers okay
so first is suppose it was incredibly
generous Bank and it gave you 12%
interest per annum not bad right maybe
there's some stupid high fees or
something like that that makes up for it
okay so opposite paren now let's start
with so much some sum of money we
generally go like a thousand dollars
that's a nice easy figure to think about
okay if it's compounded annually what
happens you stick your money in right
and for 12 months nothing happens
yeah buddy just sits there it doesn't
grow at all but then at the end of the
year right and once a year only they'll
pay you that interest and they'll pay 12
percent okay so it'll be like this after
one year right you'd have that $1,000
plus the 12% interest right so you get
this the amount would equal now do we
remember what the compound interest
formula cuz that's what this is right
what what comes first
P times what's in the brackets one plus
the rate and then what's the power and
which stands for yeah time or number of
now usually we say number of years okay
now that's fine for now but you'll see
in a second that will change okay now
let's just calculate the numbers we said
P was the principal so that's a thousand
dollars on your rate twelve percent as a
decimal what is it
zero point what yeah one twos you're
from what you okay now it's just in
there for one year so it's just a one so
one thousand times one point one two
last I checked that's what that's why in
Detroit I guess if we went for another
year we could go to through this whole
thing again and I will change this
number up here the end okay
ah but here's the food right completely
manually that's a long time to wait to
get paid your well bit interested in
this case is $120 right banks certainly
don't wait this long to pay you money
and if a bank did you probably wouldn't
go to them okay
instead of compounding annually they
will compound more frequently okay so
for instance you might have let's do
some and you'll see questions for all of
these right you might see compounded
every six months so that means they'll
do it twice in you okay now we'll talk
about whether it's better or not in a
second but let's just get down a few
different options compound every six
months the next most frequent example is
quarterly right compounded quarterly
which is every how many months that's
three months right cuz a quart of years
three months so they might say
compounded quarterly four times
thank you right I suppose they could
compound or monthly and you know you
could you could do it you could do it as
any you know any sort of time unit you
like you could do it weekly or you could
do it daily is the most common one
actually in fact your was your bank
account if you've got one and I assume
most of you do I compounded daily every
single day they're doing this kind of
calculation for you and that's why when
you get paid you only get like four or
five cents or something small like that
because it happens many many times a
year but what happens when we
if we change the situation okay let's go
compound every six months okay
let's think about our original $1000 and
our 12 percent per annum let's think
about this okay
after one year what happens okay you're
gonna get an amount right your principle
still the same it's still a thousand
okay now what's gonna happen in here hmm
I'll leave the brackets for a second
tell me what would envy it's not going
to be one anymore right it's actually
going to be - why is it - if you go
every six months right they're
compounding resist once they're
recalculating how much interest you get
right so this number up here should be a
two right so it's not just a number of
years actually a better way of saying it
is it's the yeah that's right if what's
- lots of six months or a more general
way to say it is it's the number of
compounding periods okay that's this
what's this is actually called this is a
compounding period or year or a compound
Peter of six months or three months or
one month or one day okay the
compounding period can be anything you
like
so this is the number of compounding
periods and admittedly it usually is
years but it can be anything we like now
better that's been changed to a two what
would happen if I wrote down what I
wrote before okay 0.12 okay because the
rate is 12 percent right now can anyone
tell me what's the problem with this
this is not actually how much interest
you get any takers
anyone seen what's wrong
well yes so it's time to talk or 2 to
the power to rather right but you're
getting the same amount of interest
right that's a really good deal that's
an incredible deal it's a ripoff for the
bank actually ok they're paying you the
same amount of interest but you have to
wait only half as long that's not the
way they do it ok if they're going to
recalculate twice as often they're going
to change this number in here if they do
do give you interest twice as often get
only gonna give you half as much let me
say that that's a really important that
you're gonna write underneath for you
okay if they compound or pay you twice
as often so instead of once a year they
do it twice you sorry with that well
we'll see in a second it will be close
but it won't be the same if they're paid
twice as often they will pay you half as
much I really need a new
okay so can you see what's happened yeah
12% interest over a whole year but if
you say I want it more frequently
they'll say fine but we won't pay you as
much each time if you want it twice as
often you get half as much okay what if
we went the next step down compounded
quarterly okay it's going to be well
I'll have my 1,000 at the front right
how many quarters are there in a young
their quarters right so it should be
four but they'll say if you want to get
paid four times as often
then they'll only pay move a quarter of
that which is a quarter two opposite is
three percent okay so I'm gonna have one
plus 0.03 okay so can you see this
numbers getting bigger and this number
is getting smaller this numbers getting
bigger this numbers getting smaller
let's go another step what if that if it
was monthly what would you get you're
gonna have one thousand at the front
right now how many months are there in a
year there are 12 so being that they pay
you twelve times as often they're gonna
pay you twelve times less the amount now
is zero point one two to four right or
twelve percent so how much are they
gonna pay you each month if we want this
in 0.01
a quick question for you I've got let's
see sorry
1 2 3 4 amounts on the board don't say
it out loud just think about it you're
in head which do you think would be the
best deal right is it better to get less
payments but one big hit right or a
bunch of smaller payments but more of
them now we don't need to guess because
we had calculus that could do this for
us right
we've already done it here compounded
annually there's our mouth okay now I've
got three more here so maybe what I'd do
is here we go you guys you said it okay
can I get you guys to work out what this
number is you get your calculators out
yeah you can't go to this app I can't
get this number wait for it if you read
about it you guys are here actually the
whole middle the whole middle can you
guys work out this one so this is six
monthly right
this is quarterly I can't get you guys
on the right inside the room to work out
monthly okay they are gonna be all
different answers I hope they are we all
different but it's alright let's start
with we've done we've done compounding
annually so there you go there's a
number all right um let's see Jerry can
you give me company twice a year what do
we get wait yeah so should be one
thousand and something right
I think you mean 1,000 what did you
multiply by a thousand okay all right so
keep us alive a thousand so we'll get
one thousand one hundred and six and
zero okay so hold on 3.60 bed off
through there who same amount of time
I'm more frequent okay one thousand one
hundred twenty-five and fifty cents 50
cents okay better again same amount of
time small amounts of interest but more
often okay final answer
yeah one one two six point
hey and nothing after that all right so
let's have a look let's compare our
numbers shall we we started with this
1120 okay then we got a bit extra here
we got a big actually very little bit of
extra there right in fact you can see
the further might go from here to here I
gained like 3.5 dollars from here to
here I only gained like two dollars from
here here I only gained a bit over one
dollar I'm actually slowing down right
this is interesting I left off one more
compounding daily we haven't done that
let's do that together
okay I'm gonna say Ahmet okay and this
time I want you to order write this down
because it's the trickiest one the
principle is still the same okay
it's gonna be one plus now what am I
going to put it here it was it was nice
easy numbers here right point oh six
point three was ever one what's it going
to be well let me play put this to you
okay
this is 0.12 per annum right how many
and Zeta is 1 this is 0.06 here it's
actually zero point 1 2 divided by 2
why do we divide by 2 it happened twice
a year didn't it right six months is
huffy what's this another point O three
it's actually zero point 1 2 divided by
what 4 because it was quarterly oh you
see this
and this number it matches you see that
and here of course this 0.0 where did I
get it from where I got it from a 0.12 /
well this number up here right now
therefore if I want to hear in days not
in six-month lots or three month lots or
one month lots yeah it's going to be
0.12 that's your right yeah but I divide
it by 365 the number of days here are
and then I have to raise it to a power
of four how many days there are any
which is still 365 ok let's get the
number ok
look at this compare these two numbers
what's the difference between them it is
higher though not much is it how much do
we gain we didn't even get a full dollar
we gained like 60 65 cents okay
so you can see I do get more so in
answer to our first question which is a
better deal is it better to get one big
chunk of interest or what or is it
better to get little bits of chunks of
interests but lot of them the answer is
get small chunks of interest and lots of
them that's a better deal okay yeah if
you could if you have a bank account
that will give you lots of chunks or big
interest then then ask them about their
fees just the case they're charging you
some crazy mail by the obviously what
we're considering is the same interest
being spread out over a year or being
given in one lump sum okay and we can
see that it's better to spread out over
yes yeah that's that's the game and
that's over a thousand dollars
most people will actually like once you
get a job you'll have more than a grand
in your banking you'll have several
grand right so this this gap will widen
oh yeah they go anyone how much okay
okay how about the kids to me right um
just look at this middle one under
question eight are you going to whole
bunch of different options okay
now have a look at these different
options this exercise has that um that
be tabled just before this one this one
remember that remember for the last week
okay
now the way we read it was you look for
an interest rate across the top this
that is paying age 59 and this tables
page 57 okay so we read across we said
look at interest rate up here and then
we looked for a time down the left-hand
column and then you matched up whichever
seller was supposed to be in okay now
have a look at this for instance see
this one here right ten percent for four
years ten percent for four years now if
that's all you knew you would go across
to the ten percent of column right
right alum yet and that you'd go down to
which road we chose you go to you row
number four right ten percent for years
and you get a number there it is one
point four six four okay
ah but then they tell you something else
ten percent for years compounded every
six months now it's changed think about
it think about it ten percent every year
for years now let's compound every six
months right six months so now it's not
every year right it's every six months
now I don't think about four years
anymore I think about how many lots of
six months I have how many lots are six
months out this eight right there's
eight
what's all six months or if you like
yeah eight compounding periods now I've
changed these things so I'm gonna change
this thing as well you don't get 10%
every time that be generous you're
getting it twice as often so how much
interest you yet you get half the matter
because you have five personal yeah you
know you careful they double B's right
the frequencies so then you gotta have
this
so now when you're answering this
question tips in four years you got to
go not to the ten percent column don't
go to ten percent column you've got to
go to the five percent column right and
then you have to go to the eighth row so
you go across the five percent and then
down to the eighth row which is actually
a completely different number which
makes sense because we saw as you change
the compounding period you get different
amounts of money okay so you have to be
very careful when you read those the
different compounding periods change the
question entirely